JAMES.
>> Stan: A STEPBACK AGAINST VERY
GOOD DEFENSE HERE BY KENRICH
WILLIAMS.
MADE HIM EARN IT.
>> Brian: PRESENTATION COMING.
>> Announcer: LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, YOUR ATTENTION,
PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME, JOIN US IN
HONORING LeBRON JAMES!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
TURN YOUR ATTENTION NOW TO THE
VIDEO BOARD AS WE BEGIN OUR
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
>> WELL, SIMPLY PUT, DAN, LeBRON
JAMES IS THE BEST HIGH SCHOOL
BASKETBALL PLAYER I HAVE EVER
SEEN.
>> HE'S THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
COUNTRY AND I WANT TO KEEP IT
THAT WAY.
>> FROM THE 2003 NBA DRAFT, THE
CLEVELAND CAVALIERS SELECT
LeBRON JAMES FOR THE MOST
ANTICIPATED VENUE OF ANY
FIRST-YEAR ATHLETE IN ANY SPORT.
>> LeBRON JAMES, THE YOUNGEST
PLAYER WITH 10,000 POINTS.
>> LeBRON JAMES WITH NO RECOURSE
FOR HUMAN LIFE!
>> THERE IT IS.
THE QUICKEST TO 30,000.
LeBRON JAMES, ONE OF THE
ALL-TIME GREATS.
♪♪
>> IT'S BACK-TO-BACK TITLES FOR
THE HEAT.
NBA CHAMPIONSHIP BELONGS TO THE
LOS ANGELES LAKERS.
>> THE LEGEND OF LeBRON
CONTINUES.
HE DOMINATES.
>> JAMES HAS PASSED SHAQUILLE
O'NEAL.
>> AND THERE IT IS.
NOW NUMBER TWO ALL-TIME IN
SCORING.
♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Announcer: AND NOW, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, AT CENTER COURT,
NBA COMMISSIONER ADAM SILVER IS
JOINED BY THE LEGEND WHO HAS
HELD THE ALL-TIME SCORING RECORD
SINCE 1984.
THE CAPTAIN, KAREEM
ABDUL-JABBAR!
>> A RECORD THAT HAS STOOD FOR
NEARLY 40 YEARS, WHICH KAREEM
MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT WOULD NEVER
BE BROKEN.
LeBRON, YOU ARE THE NBA'S
ALL-TIME SCORING LEADER!
CONGRATULATIONS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE NEW ALL-TIME SCORING LEADER
NUMBER 6, LeBRON JAMES!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪